AND TUCKER CARLSON IS COMING UP
NEXT.
MUSICAL PHYSICAL >> Tucker:
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO THE
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR MORE THAN TWO CENTURIES, THE
U.S. SENATE HAS REQUIRED SUPPORT
OF AT LEAST 60 SENATORS BEFORE
THEY PASSED MAJOR PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AND THAT MAKES FOR A
CUMBERSOME SYSTEM.
IT REQUIRES COMPROMISE AND
PATIENTS.
IT HAS ENDURED THROUGH THE
CENTURIES.
DESPITE LEADERSHIP OF THE BODY,
AND THAT STANDARD, OF 60 VOTES
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
FILIBUSTER RULE, AND IT’S A
DEMOCRACY, AND SO WHEN PEOPLE
NOTE, YOU HAD BETTER BE CERTAIN
THAT A LARGE MAJORITY OF YOUR
CITIZENS SUPPORT WHAT YOU ARE
DOING AS A PRINCIPLE BEHIND THE
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
WHATEVER YOU DO AS A LAWMAKER,
YOU BETTER BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
IT.
WHATEVER YOU ARE DOING IS WISE
AND WON’T HURT HER GRANDCHILDREN
IN WAYS THAT YOU HADN’T BOTHERED
TO THINK THROUGH AND THAT’S WHY
FOR 214 YEARS WE REQUIRED A
SUPER MAJORITY IN THE SENATE.
IT’S NOT JUST AN ARCANE PIECE OF
SENATE PROCEDURE, I WONDER IF
PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT ATTITUDES
TOOK CONTROL OF PEOPLE IN OUR
SYSTEM.
WHAT IF THESE NEW PEOPLE DIDN’T
CARE ABOUT THE WISDOM, WHAT IF
THEY DIDN’T BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY?
WHAT IF THEY CONSIDER DEBATE AND
PERSUASION, WINNING PEOPLE OVER?
INSTEAD, INTENDED TO RULE BY
FORCE.
WHAT IF ALL THESE PEOPLE CARRIED
ABOUT WITH POWER?
IT WOULD BE AN OBSTACLE IN YOUR
PATH TO TOTAL CONTROL.
THEY NEVER WERE DIRECTED ABOUT
ANYTHING.
IN FACT THEY DESPISE CLEAR AND
PRECISE ENGLISH.
INSTEAD THEY WOULD RELY ON
FELINE MISDIRECTION, THEY LIE
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
THEY THEMSELVES WERE COMMITTING,
AND IF THEY WANTED TO TURN THE
PARTY INTO A ONE-PARTY STATE,
THEY WOULDN’T SAY THAT OUT LOUD.
INSTEAD, ANYONE WHO OPPOSE THAT
GOAL OF "PARTISANSHIP, THEY
WOULDN’T EVEN SMILE AS THEY SAID
IT.
WATCH.
>> WHEN THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE AGAIN, IF
MITCH McCONNELL TRIES TO DO
WHAT HE DID TO PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND PUT SMALL MINDED
PARTISANSHIP AHEAD OF SOLVING A
MASSIVE COUNTRY, WE SHOULD GET
RID OF THE FILIBUSTER.
>> SMALL MINDED PARTISANSHIP.
THEY SERVED THE U.S. SENATE FOR
DECADES AND SUPPORTED THE
FILIBUSTER WHEN HE WAS THERE.
WE WILL CUT THEM OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
>> THEY SUGGESTED THAT WE BE
OPEN TO ELIMINATING THE
FILIBUSTER IF REPUBLICANS
OBSTRUCT THE AGENDA.
ARE YOU MORE RECEPTIVE TO TAKING
A LOOK BEHIND THAT?
JOB NUMBER ONE IS TO GET THE
MAJORITY.
THE SECOND WE TAKE CONTROL, WE
ARE GETTING RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER.
>> HOW DO WE JUSTIFY, AND ON
WHAT GROUNDS.
WE JUSTIFY THAT THE SAME WAY WE
JUSTIFIED TEARING DOWN ANCIENT
STATUES.
AND THEY WROTE A PIECE, BECAUSE
APPARENTLY AND, THERE’S A LOT AT
STAKE IN THIS CONVERSATION.
BUT THE LAST CHECK AND BALANCE
GONE, THERE WILL BE NO LIMIT TO
THE WAYS THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN REMAKE THE
COUNTRY IN THE FIRST FEW MONTHS
AND THE POWER.
WE DON’T HAVE TO GUESS ABOUT
THEIR PLANS, THEY TOLD US WHAT
THEY HAVE PLANS TO DO AND
WITHOUT, THAT’S CRIMINALS AND
BEHAVIOR AND CRUSHES INDEPENDENT
MEDIA VOICES IN THIS CHANNEL.
THAT PAST A LUNATIC PRENEW DEAL
WHICH DOES NOTHING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND DOES AN AWFUL
LOT FOR THE CONTROL OF THE
COUNTRY.
THEY WILL CALL THAT IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
THEIR CORE VOTERS ARE DEMANDING